im weltraum sammelt sich immer mehr müll
an der nicht nur das leben der
astronauten gefährdet sondern auch
zunehmend unser leben hier auf der erde
bedroht mini satelliten wie aus einem
lego baukasten soll das problem lösen
jetzt den krieg zum science fiction laut
experten befinden sich rund 6300 tonnen
schrott im weltraum die trümmer und
gegenstände die eine mindestgröße von
zehn zentimetern haben werden vom space
surveillance network des us-militärs
erfasst und verfolgt aktuell befinden
sich demzufolge rund 17.000 objekte mal
davon sind knapp 9500 bruchstücke also
mehr als die hälfte ist schrott dieser
weltraummüll kann alles mögliche sein
ausgediente satelliten ausgebrannte
raketenstufen oder abgeplatzte lack oder
trümmerstücke viele der bruchstücke sind
bei militärischen test sogenannte anti
satelliten waffen entstanden
diese sollen gegnerische raumflugkörper
durch rammen beschuss oder in deren nähe
ausgelösten explosionen zerstören
der letzte test dieser art im jahr 2011
verursachte allein mehr als 3.300
fragmente und und dieser müll ist
hochgefährlich am 10 februar 2009
kollidierte ein aktiver satelliten mit
einem abgeschalteten beide flugkörper
wurden dabei zerstört und produzierten
noch mehr weltraumschrott so können
kettenreaktionen wie im hollywood film
gravity entstehen
einige der schrottteile werden
allerdings nach ein paar tagen oder
monaten in der erdatmosphäre vernichtet
die dünnen oberen schichten bremsen sie
an bis in richtung erdoberfläche stürzen
durch den luftwiderstand und der damit
verbundenen hohen reibung der
erdatmosphäre verglühen sie dann das
problem aber ist dass größere teile
nicht immer vollständig vergnügen sie
schlagen auf der erde auf das ist vor
drei jahren das letzte mal passiert im
september 2011 stürzten teile eines
amerikanischen satelliten gott sei dank
in den pazifik eine weitaus größere
gefahr geht allerdings von dem schrott
aus der sich weiterhin im weltraum
befinden er kann das leben auf der erde
bedrohen
das liegt daran dass die schrottteile
eine extrem hohe geschwindigkeit
entwickeln die teile können mit einem
tempo von 50.000 stundenkilometern
aufeinander
heiner klinkrad der chef für
weltraumtrümmer also der abteilung die
für weltraumtrümmer zuständig ist bei
der esa hat das folgendermaßen
verglichen
wenn eine aluminium kugel von gerade mal
einem zentimeter durchmesser so auf
einen satelliten trifft hat sie die
energie eines mittelklassewagens der mit
etwa 50 kilometern pro stunde in ihn
hinein fährt da unser alltag vollständig
auf satelliten angewiesen ist könnte ein
zusammenprall dieser weltraumtrümmer mit
satten schwerwiegende konsequenzen haben
denn ohne satelliten geht nichts mehr
auf unserem planeten logistik
flugverkehr wissenschaft landwirtschaft
und nicht zuletzt die gesamte
kommunikation hängen von ihnen ab für
die entsorgung des weltraummülls gibt es
bereits einige ideen ist könnte zum
beispiel ein friedhofs orbit
eingerichtet werden also eine umlaufbahn
speziell nur für schrott und in japan
wurde ein so genannter
elektromagnetischer pfeffer entwickelt
mit ihm soll der weltraumschrott
eingesammelt werden und auf dem weg zur
erde verglühen und dabei auch noch strom
erzeugen
allerdings gibt es noch einige probleme
in der praktischen umsetzung die
verantwortlichen wissenschaftler
vermuten dass ein einsatz frühestens
2019 möglich wird eine ganz andere
lösung haben jetzt forscher unter
anderem auch aus deutschland entwickelt
mit neuartigen satelliten soll der
weltraumschrott erst gar nicht mehr
entstehen
das konzept ähnelt dabei einem lego
baukasten
die neuen satelliten sollen kleiner sein
und aus einzelnen würfel komponenten
zusammengesetzt sein jeder der würfel
hat eine eigene aufgabe
das bedeutet es gibt einen batterie
würfel einen würfel mit einer kamera
einen für messgeräte und so weiter ist
einer der bausteine defekt kann er
leicht von einem service satelliten
ausgetauscht werden diese kleineren
satellit netten viele vorteile sie sind
leichter und somit auch einfacher in den
orbit zu bringen zudem kosten sie
weniger erst kürzlich hat google die
firma skybox imager aufgekauft das
unternehmen baut mini satelliten mit
standard elektronik und standardteilen
aus der automobil- oder smartphone
industrie mit neuen kleinen satelliten
soll unter anderem die
internetverbindung auch in entlegenen
gebieten des globus verfügbar sein und
auch die hilfe bei umweltkatastrophen
könnte so verbessert werden
der größte vorteil wäre allerdings dass
keine wegwerf systeme ins all geschossen
werden wie diplom ingenieurin jana weise
erklärt
sie ist koordinatorin des projektes mit
dem langen namen intelligente baukasten
konzepte für das on orbit satellit sind
servicing kurz ipos das langfristige
ziel ist satelliten zu standardisieren
und somit weltweit einheitliche
komponenten zu produzieren damit könnte
der weltraummüll gar nicht mehr
entstehen
aber nicht nur weltraumschrott bedroht
die erde auch asteroiden stellen eine
riesige gefahr für die welt da alles zum
thema erkläre ich in diesem video hier
klicken dafür und täglich news zur
wissenschaft gibt es in der app und im
block dafür
hier klicken allerdings auch in der
video beschreibung was meint ihr können
wir den weltraumschrott in den griff
bekommen oder wird bald eine ähnliche
katastrophe wie in graffiti passieren
was sind eure lösungsvorschläge für die
beseitigung oder die verhinderung des
mülls diskutiert es wie immer mit mir in
den kommentaren ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran